reste dans l'économie avec peut-être
peut-être un changement dans le secteur
de la mode
l'un des plus grand magazine féminin
allemand vient d'annoncer qu'il ne fera
plus posé des mannequins professionnels
dans ses pages
motif la dictature de la minceur et
parfois de la maigreur qui peut mener à
l'anorexie en espagne en italie des
mesures concrètes ont également été
prises toute l'europe est concernée peu
à peu c'est le dossier de cette édition
il est signé sophie mais elle christophe
kenck quand il dessine ses silhouettes
graciles le couturier franck sorbier a
bien conscience que ces femmes sont un
peu irréel tout en jambes filiformes
mais de là à vouloir les retrouver sur
son podium il s'en défend
et pourtant voici à quoi ressemblait la
mariée de son dernier défilé pas bien
épaisse vraiment elle a choqué beaucoup
de gens moi je ne me suis pas part parce
que c'est vrai que la robe était très
courte qu'on a vu qu'elle avait des
légendes comme ça des petites quilles
quoi je pense que ce qui m'a plus
justement là dedans c'est le fait de ce
côté justement très juvénile un peu un
peu petite fille qui a grandi trop vite
connaît au fil des années les
silhouettes des mannequins deviennent de
plus en plus frêle alors même que le
débat sur leur trop grande maigreur ne
cesse de faire polémique
on admettait 1,36 ou 38 il ya encore
quelques saisons
la norme est aujourd'hui 1,34 fillette
les mannequins sont effectivement très
maigres mais elles le sont aussi parce
qu'il faut se souvenir qu'avant d'être
un spectacle qui passent en direct sur
internet
les défilés c'est un outil de
communication pour des marques qui sont
compétitions les unes contre les autres
quand on est en compétition on essaye
d'avoir les meilleurs outils quand on
est couturiers et créateurs
on essaye d'avoir les corps qui met le
mieux en valeur les vêtements
une équation régit la norme en matière
de poids celle indice de masse
corporelle ou imc natalia 1 m 80 pour 48
kg 1 ni mc de 14,8
alors que la norme se situe entre 18 et
demi et 25 jean à 1 m 83 pour 63 kg à l
âne imc de 18,8 dans la norme mais
considéré comme trop ronde elle a
préféré arrêter momentanément sa
carrière plutôt que de m'écrire regard
lagerfeld c'est la société elle-même qui
n'accepte plus les chiros mi mai les
groupes et p quand une fille connue 33
pilot enduro tabua les grosses elle est
moche elle à la cellulite et il n'a pas
regardé
ils sont là que se taper des des chips
et où la société s'est transformée dans
une société un peu de spectateurs et de
voyeurs pourtant en europe
le milieu de la mode est déjà en train
de réagir le magazine allemand brigitte
fait cent mille exemplaires vient de
décider de ne plus faire appel à des
mannequins en 2010 il y aura des femmes
ordinaires
je veux montrent des femmes qui mènent
une vie normale qui travaillent à des
femmes qui ont leur propre personnalité
l'espagne est encore plus radicale avant
les défilés les mannequins doivent
passer le test de la pesée les trop
maigres sont recalés que l'on veut faire
ici c'est éviter que la maigreur extrême
soit donné en exemple durant les défilés
cette décision radicale prise déjà il y
a trois ans est encore unique au monde
il ya encore du chemin